question from davey who says to
professor chomsky the mind body problem
how can chomsky make the transposition
from newton's demolishment of the notion
of physical in the natural sciences to
the rejection of the concept of body in
the mind body problem does this
dismissal mean that professor chomsky
believes there is no material world and
only the mental aspects
well we're talking about the 17th
century
and the 17th century body just meant
some part of the physical world
it was
there's a narrower sense of body in
which it means
my shoulder my arms and so on but they
weren't talking about that
uh actually descartes was in his
de long has
the last volume of his uh
lemon
which was never published
out of concern for the church
and but there he does talk about
you know the structure of the body you
know
in the narrow sense of body
you know your ribs your digestive system
and so on you're thinking
how they're related it's where he brings
up the pineal gland
pineal gland as the point in which
they're connected so there he's using a
narrower sense of body but the
discussion about body is just discussion
about matter
so it's not
my
distinction that's just right you have
no notion of matter you have no notion
of body
uh this stuff here
is all made of matter
and if i don't understand what matter is
i
i'm gonna have some understanding what
this is but that's consciousness the
things i we all understand but when you
ask what's it constituted of
well
some kind of whatever the world is
constituted
but since newton we have
no real concept of that
physical material body that's
just whatever we think the world is
constituted of
i'm in uh
physicist
john wheeler the
institute for advanced study
once advanced a
theory that's called it from bit
uh says the only thing that exists in
the universe
is bits of information
answers to questions that we pose
bit
everything else the it part is just our
constructions from that
i don't know if it's a good theory or
not i'm not that competent the physicist
but suppose it is
okay that's matter
it's
if it's something else okay
right now
physicists are in a strange situation
where they can't find
i think it's 95
of what they
have to assume
the world is constituted of
dark matter dark energy
can't find it it's got to be there or
the
the
the the predictions don't come out the
theory doesn't work so it's got to be
there but you can't find it
whatever it is that's matter
all of this on the last part of the
question
i've always been
persuaded by
what's called in the history of
philosophy
suggestion
referring to john locke's
reaction immediate reaction
to newton's principia which he knew at
once
uh
luck
well he put it within his
theological framework we can restrain it
restate it without the theological
framework but
putting it in his terms
just as
god
provided matter
with properties that we cannot
comprehend
as
mr newton has shown
so god might have
super added to matter
the property of thought
meaning certain
organized
parts of
whatever the world consists of
maybe something in our brain
uh produces thought
just as
general matter has properties like
attraction and repulsion
can't understand it but that's the way
god made things
well that's block suggestion it led to a
century of
careful inquiry
into how
organized
matter whatever matter is
can produce thought
david hume
joseph priestly
tree
many others finds its way to
darwin's notebooks
just as
you know
the liver produces
while why can't the brain produce
thoughts
that was the idea through the 19th
century
then 18th century
then pretty much forgotten
interestingly it was revived
in the last decade of the 20th century
uh regarded as a
radical new idea in the history of
philosophy
thinking is just the property of
organized matter
uh
astonishing hypothesis and so on
the new idea
in modern biology
repeating in almost verbatim
the writings of the 18th century
i've written about this so it was
rediscovered and if there's an
alternative i don't know what it is
uh
thinking
what's mental
is just
some kind of property of certain types
of organized matter
notice this leaves open what matter is
whatever it turns out to be whatever the
world is constituted of
but certain organizations of it do have
the property of thought
and we can now say fair amount about
that
we know that it's above the neck not
below the neck so you can cut off my arm
i still think the same way
decapitate me i don't think the same way
and when you look inside the head
it's not in the nose it's in the brain
you can find particular parts of the
brain which
implicated in
one or another kind of thought so you
can now carry out the
17th century
insights lock
in
more specific directions
so as to whether
there's no material world only the
mental aspects
there's a material world by definition
the material world we define as whatever
there is
so there's something not nothing
so therefore there's a material world
whatever it is we don't know what it is
we don't know what its properties are we
know some of its properties
like some of its properties are
attraction and repulsion
other of its properties are thinking
many other properties
uh mental aspects of the world are just
part of the material world
don't see any point in distinguishing
them
there are chemical aspects to the world
there are mental aspects to the world
of course they're different we can study
them and so on
but i don't see
um there is a kind of
methodological dualism
which holds that we have to study
the mind differently from other parts of
the world
quine was an example of this
his approach to
mental aspects of the worlds in word and
object was radically unscientific in my
view i've written about this
didn't just treated it dogmatically
language is
a complex of dispositions to verbal
behavior acquired by conditioning
it's an edict it's not a scientific
proposal
and it collapses instantly on
examination but it didn't matter
because we keep two
methodological dualism we don't use the
methods of science when we
study the mind of course quine would
deny that and did deny it but if you
look at it i think that's the right
conclusion and you can say the same
thing about all of behaviorism
behaviorism i think was a radical
departure from the sciences
i mean the science is a
typical
comment about the sciences which i think
is fair enough is uh
john pierre baptiste physicist's
nobel prize
lecturer when he won the physics prize
he said
the goal of science is to
discover the
simple invisibles that lie behind the
complex visibles
behavioral science is saying let's just
look at the complex visibles
we're not allowed to look at the hidden
invisibles in other words we're not
allowed to do science
you can't think of a more
radical departure from science and for
the 20th century it's been considered
scientific
i think that's a
serious departure from science which
swept the intellectual world